Congratulations.
You are well on your way to
building fantastic forms.
You've been building forms that take
less time and help users along the way.
>> Yes, and you know how to build
better inputs, faster phones, and
reactive touch interfaces.
You've got all the tools you need
to make your phones a breeze and
increase conversions.
And most importantly, you've been
developing the right mindset for
tackling forms in the future.
>> Right.
So get out there and
build some forms to convert more users.
If this course has helped you out, head
over to the forums and share your story.
Thanks for learning with us.
>> Be strong and happy.
Bye bye.